I'm in Washington standing in front of
the Supreme Court building we're in 2004
2006 and 2008 the Supreme Court declared
that the Bush administration had acted
outside the law and had to stop an issue
where policies that Bush had put in
place after the terrorist attacks of
September 11 2001 which it concluded
that the United States was engaged in a
new kind of war that required a
different set of rules captured enemy
combatants instead of being tried in
regularly constituted courts would be
tried in secret military tribunals those
that were thought to have important
information would be subject to harsh
interrogation including waterboarding
which the United States had condemned as
torture when used on American soldiers
in world war ii Korea and Vietnam in one
case the Supreme Court said that the
Bush administration had violated the
Constitution in another case the Supreme
Court said that has violated the laws of
Congress and the Geneva Conventions in
his final decision the Supreme Court
rejected the Bush administration's claim
that the president alone had authority
to decide the rules of law during time
of war that judgment said the court
belongs to us the court not to the
president
the Supreme Court in those decisions was
acting as the framers of the
Constitution would have preferred in the
words of John Adams the nation's second
president the Constitution was designed
to create a government of laws rather
than of men
[Music]
[Music]
century after the US Constitution was
written William Gladstone the four-time
Prime Minister of Britain declared it to
be the most wonderful work ever struck
off by the brain and purpose of man
Gladstone admired the Constitution for
the precedent it set the nation's
highest authority would be the words of
a document rather than the dictates of
the top ruler today we take that idea
for granted but in 1787 when the
Constitution was written it was a
revolutionary idea elsewhere in the
world the law was what the king said it
was his word was law America would be
governed instead by a constitution that
put limits on what those in power could
do in this session we'll look at why the
framers of the Constitution were
determined to limit the power of
government then we'll look at how they
built the concept of limited government
into the Constitution finally we'll
examine whether the Constitution has
actually served as an effective check on
government the American Revolution was
fought to overthrow what the Declaration
of Independence called the absolute
tyranny of the British King the framers
worried that the u.s. government might
itself become tyrannical it is said that
Benjamin Franklin asked by a woman what
type of government the Constitution had
created replied a republic ma'am if you
can keep it how do you prevent
government from becoming tyrannical you
might think it's a constitution that
strips government of nearly all power
some Americans today think that way a US
Senate candidate recently ran on a
platform they claimed the government
which governs best is the government
that governs least the writers of the
Constitution knew better a lesson they
had learned the hard way when the
American states declared the
independence from Britain they wrote a
constitution called the Articles of
Confederation the Articles established a
national government but gave it almost
no authority it had no power to
but instead had to petition the states
for money the states were slow to pay
and often paid less than their promised
share during one five-year period
Georgia and North Carolina paid nothing
not a single dime to the National
Treasury so think about your own
finances what do you do when you're
short of cash
well for starters you'll probably cut
back on your spending you get really
desperate you might try to sell your
valuables well that's exactly what the
government of the Articles did to save
money it slashed the army to less than a
thousand men to raise money it sold the
Navy ships this at a time when Britain
still had a large army in Canada and
Spain had one in what is now Florida how
would the country defend itself if
attacked by Britain or Spain no wonder
that George Washington questioned
whether the United States deserved even
to be called a nation and worried that
it would descend into chaos opening the
door to a tyrannical leader now the
Constitution was meant to fix the
defects in the Articles of Confederation
but the writers were also determined
that the new government not be so strong
as to threaten Liberty so their strategy
was to grant the national government
necessary powers including the power to
tax well at the same time placing strict
limits on its authority the strategy
included denials of power officials
would be prohibited for example from
putting someone in prison and throwing
away the keys this was a common practice
at the time in Europe opponents of the
king were locked away for as long as the
king wanted forever in many cases that
practice would be prohibited in the
United States the Constitution gives the
accused the right to appear before a
judge who will determine whether
authorities have enough evidence to
warrant detention the writers also
sought to limit government through
grants of power article 1 of the
Constitution the very first article of
the Constitution gives Congress 17
specific powers such as the power to tax
the power to raise an army and navy the
power to regulate commerce
these grants give power but they also
deny power powers not granted to
Congress those not on the list are
denied it in a period of history when
other governments admitted to no limits
on their powers this was a substantial
limitation as originally written the US
Constitution did not include a bill of
rights a list of specific individual
rights such as freedom of speech the
framers thought a list was unnecessary
because government had only those powers
granted to it and it had not been
granted the power to deny people their
rights Thomas Jefferson was among the
many who thought otherwise Jefferson had
included a Bill of Rights in the
Virginia Constitution he wrote at the
outbreak of the Revolutionary War and
other states had followed his example
said Jefferson the Bill of Rights is
what the people are entitled to against
every government on earth in response to
such objections the first Congress
passed a series of amendments that were
quickly ratified by the states these
amendments the first tenth of the
Constitution are called the Bill of
Rights the Bill of Rights is a clear
example of limited government if you
were arrested tomorrow and had no money
the judge doesn't have the option of
saying tough luck buddy
the government is required by the sixth
amendment to provide you a lawyer and to
pay for now the framers didn't think
that words alone written grants and
denials would be enough to control those
in power they wanted something stronger
that something was to divide the
government into separate branches and
pit them against each other this was not
a new idea
the French theorist Montesquieu had
proposed it nearly a half a century
earlier where there is no separation of
powers he wrote there can be no Liberty
but the framers gave Montesquieu's idea
a new twist rather than completely
separating the branches as he had
proposed they overlapped them so that
each was better positioned to act as a
check on the others so instead of
granting all legislative power to
Congress they gave some of it to the
Pres
for example the power to veto laws and
some of it to the courts the power to
interpret laws the same with executive
power the president has most of it but
not all of it for example Congress
controls how much money the president
can spend and on what the president
doesn't have the option of taking money
allocated for highways and spending it
on the military the same with judicial
power for example by giving the
president the power to nominate federal
judges and the Senate the power to
confirm them the system of divided power
was described by Harvard's Richard
Newsted as one of separated institutions
sharing power the powers of government
legislative executive and judicial are
granted two separate branches but no
branch has all power within its sphere
of authority part of it in every case is
shared with the other two branches
providing them a means of checking that
branches power so that's the theory each
branch acting as a check on the others
now as you know theory and reality
aren't always the same thing the English
poet John Wilmot quipped before I got
married I had six theories about raising
children now I have six children and no
theories what about the framers theory
well the record is far from perfect
after Japan attacked US forces at Pearl
Harbor in December 1941 President
Franklin Roosevelt ordered the forced
relocation of more than a hundred
thousand japanese-americans from the
West Coast saying they might try to help
the enemy they were forced to sell their
homes at rock-bottom prices and were
shipped to detention camps in Utah and
other inland states they lived out the
war behind barbed wire washed over by
armed guards their advocates looked to
Congress for help instead Congress
embraced Roosevelt's policy not a single
senator or House member voted to rescind
it three times the Supreme Court
reviewed the policy each time it upheld
it though it was clearly
unconstitutional racism played into the
relocation policy America had a long
history of discriminating again
stations Chinese were blocked from entry
in 1883 Japanese immigration was
effectively blocked in 1907 when the
survivors of the Titanic arrived by
rescue ship in New York Harbor in 1912
they were taken ashore except for a
handful of Chinese crewmen they were not
allowed to set foot on American soil
ironically japanese-americans were
allowed during World War Two to
volunteer for combat in Europe they made
up the entirety of the US Army's 440
second regiment that regiment became the
most decorated combat unit of its size
not only in world war ii but in the
whole of US military history 21 of its
soldiers received the Congressional
Medal of Honor the nation's highest
award in 1988 the United States issued a
formal apology for its mistreatment of
Japanese Americans saying it was the
result of race prejudice war hysteria
and a failure of political leadership as
the relocation policy indicates America
is not a stranger to tyranny the
powerful trampling on the rights of the
weak such episodes however are
relatively few a number and the system
of checks and balances is a reason
scores of times the President Congress
or the Supreme Court has intervened when
another branch has overstepped its
constitutional authority the Watergate
scandal is a textbook example on a June
night in 1972 a security guard at the
Watergate buildings in Washington DC
noticed that the latch on the door to
the Democratic Party's national
headquarters had been taped open he
removed the tape and went away coming
back later he noticed the door had been
taped open again he called police they
caught five men inside installing bugs
in the phones and ceilings as it turned
out they had links to President Richard
Nixon's reelection campaign
Nixon denied that anyone at the White
House had knowledge of the break-in in
truth the Watergate break-in was part of
a much larger dirty-tricks campaign
aimed at guaranteeing Nixon's
re-election the dirty tricks included
wiretap tax audits burglaries of Nixon
opponents paid in part with money
laundered illegally through Mexico a
turning point occurred when during a
Senate investigative hearing a white
house assistant revealed that Nixon had
tape recorded all his Oval Office
conversations Nixon had first refused
Congress's demand to hear the tapes as
the pressure mounted he released
transcripts of what he claimed were all
the relevant ones when Congress demanded
more tape material Nixon refused
Congress then filed suit to get the
tapes in a unanimous decision the US
Supreme Court which included four nixon
appointees ordered Nixon to turn over
the tapes they were incriminating Nixon
was heard telling his assistants to
cover up the Watergate break-in
including using the CIA to block the FBI
from investigating it with that the
House of Representatives began
impeachment hearings at that point Nixon
resigned the first and only president to
do so
President Nixon despite holding what is
often called the most powerful office on
earth was powerless to stop Congress and
the Supreme Court from acting the
writers of the Constitution had
established them as separate and
independent branches of government and
they acted in precisely that way
now as I'm sure you recognize America's
system of checks and balances doesn't
always operate that decisively politics
is a rough and sometimes deceitful game
what if the Watergate burglars had not
been so stupid as to get caught what
Nixon's illegal action have been
discovered in time to do anything
meaningful about it
presidential secrecy is one of the major
threats to the effectiveness of
America's system of checks and balances
congressional secrecy is not a problem
Congress has 535 members and it couldn't
keep a secret of a tribe the presidency
is different presidents have the loyalty
of their trusted assistants and secrets
can sometimes be kept until it's too
late to make a difference the relocation
policy during World War two illustrates
another threat to the proper working of
the system in that case all three
branches thought a breach of the
Constitution served the nation's
interest in time of war
there's another threat that has shown
itself to be important it can be seen in
a situation we discussed earlier the
Bush administration's anti-terrorism
policies as mentioned the September 11
terrorist attacks convinced the Bush
administration that the war on terrorism
required a new set of rules the rules
for handling enemy captives were hatched
in secrecy to keep them from scrutiny by
Congress they were also kept secret from
those in the administration including
Secretary of State and former Army
General Colin Powell who would have
objected slowly information about the
policies leaked out in some instances
through news stories and other instances
through legal cases being argued in
federal courts as the information came
out there were calls for congressional
hearings but almost none were held even
the Supreme Court rulings in 2004 and
2006 against Bush administration
policies did not prompt Congress to
launch high-profile hearings then in
2007 the number of congressional
hearings increased dramatically why was
that
why was Congress initially slow to
scrutinize Bush policies
but then suddenly eager to do so as you
might have guessed the answer is
partisanship through 2006 Republicans
controlled the House and the Senate and
thereby controlled the scheduling of
hearings they were not at all interested
in holding a Republican administration
to account for its policies knowing that
it would hurt their party things changed
abruptly after Democrats swept the 2006
congressional elections and took control
of the House and Senate in early 2007
Democrats now controlled the hearing
process and they called one hearing
after another seeking partisan advantage
they were keen to grill the Bush
administration on its war policies okay
let's wrap up what we've said in this
session as we noted the Constitution was
designed in part to provide for limited
government meaning a government not so
powerful as to threaten Liberty the
Constitution contains various controls
and government including grants of power
and denials of power however the key
mechanism is the separation of powers
between the three branches the executive
the legislature and the judicial the
powers of the branches are overlapped so
that each branch can more effectively
act as a check on the others the system
doesn't always work as intended it
weakens when as in the world war ii
relocation policy the three branches are
united in thinking that the national
interest is served by ignoring the
constitution it weakens when a president
succeeds even for time to keep unlawful
actions secret and it weakens when the
presidency and Congress are controlled
by the same party then the majority
party in Congress might seek to play
down the issue although the u.s. system
is not a perfect check on power the
record also shows that on many occasions
dozens and dozens of them it has helped
to rein in abuses of power we'll never
know of course how US history would have
differed if the Constitution had not
been based on a system of checks and
balances but the fact that some leaders
have tried to operate outside the law
suggests they would have done so more
readily
and more outrageously if the other
branches had been powerless to check
their actions there was a great deal of
wisdom and what John Adams said in a
letter to Thomas Jefferson I say that
power must never be trusted without a
check
you